foreign
how can I move past
the history that I had with my husband
while he was drinking now that he is
sober and is it even possible the last
few months have just been I I can't get
intimate with him I can barely hug him
how come
like where did what is your body trying
to protect you from
[Music]
yo yo yo yo yo what's up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast ever
ever
[Music]
statement it's mostly not true it's
mostly true and I'm so glad you've
joined us
um if you want to be on this show this
this show is is real calls from real
people and I pull up a seat at the bar
and listen to what's going on and we
figure out what to do next we make the
next right decision if you want to be on
the show talk about what's going on in
your life it can be just about anything
man we'll talk about all of it give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291
1-844-693-3291 and you leave a message
and Jenna or Kelly will call you back or
you can go to John deloney.com
ask all right so let's get right into it
we're gonna have some fun I got a letter
from Kyle and then his wife also wrote
an uh wrote a letter Amber Kyle and
Amber
yeah you ever played poker with me if
someone's like uh
I call or I'll raise you I'll raise you
I'll raise you I love call so Kyle I'm
calling
both figuratively and literally here we
go
foreign
yes this is him Kyle this deloney what
are you doing
no way yeah yeah dude you wrote me a
letter
dude this is really you I hear your
voice that's really me
um hey and you're on the air so don't
say anything dumb that's gonna get you
fired okay how are you y'all doing well
wow I'm doing well and uh man really
well now you called I was just working
away I'm a numbers guy and now my day
just got fun so this is cool what kind
of numbers do you do
dude I'm an accountant spreadsheets
bookkeeping taxes formulas that's just
uh my happy place I just died a little
bit on the inside in my guts except I
don't know the sum equals or the equal
sum uh algorithms I know how that works
that puts you like top eighty percent I
think
okay so me and Dave Ramsey a couple
other folks um some of the gang here
were coming to San Antonio to do an
event and you and your wife both wrote
me separate letters asking hey could we
sold out the whole thing's sold out and
you want it backstage passes like it's
Wayne's World what do you want to do man
dude I'm well I saw there was like an
upgraded tier just to shake your hand
and say hi I mean we're just huge fans
and that that's that's what I'm looking
for and we're definitely going to go to
the event and have a great time but I
was just I saw they already sold out by
the time I seen that I saw the thing I
logged in and it was already like
backstage gone so I'm like man hopefully
a handwritten letter might be the
special special ones here to convince
them and then and I I also wanted I
don't know I just like love playing
basketball I hear you you mess around a
little bit street ball and then a little
bit of CrossFit just try to make your
time enjoyable while you're here in San
Antonio so I will pass on basketball
um I've had some I ended up in two knee
surgeries last time I played basketball
and it was like a church league thing
man it was not great but
nice I am going to do some hard-hitting
Mexican food when I'm in San Antonio so
I got me covered hey I got you guys okay
here's what you're gonna do when you
show up I want you to let the people at
the know at the on the entryway that
you're Kyle and you're the guy that
wrote the letter and
um that you're supposed to meet with
deloney and they'll get in touch with me
and we'll make it happen is that cool
wow thank you so much Dr John that just
made my day you're amazing man thank you
awesome hey thanks for writing me a
letter I love getting mail and uh thanks
for sending a picture here's what's cool
I don't know which one of these dudes
you are in this photo there's this
beautiful woman and two guys and I'm
just gonna guess you're the other guy so
that's very cool man hey have an awesome
day get back to your uh spreadsheeting
um that almost sounded vulgar but get
back to your spreadsheeting and we'll
party from there is that cool
awesome thank you so much all right hey
brother uh hold on hold on the line real
quick and uh General pick up thanks man
all right all right thanks
all right
see just write me letters I love getting
snail mail I love getting snail mail
like I'm a middle schooler and I just
got back from like summer camp and
there's no social media and I realized I
just dated myself and I'm a thousand
years old now all right
um hey and we're gonna be taking some
more live events on the road um
especially uh the spring if you want us
to come to your town shoot me a direct
message and we'll see if we can set that
up we're gonna really hit the road this
spring
um let's go out to Los Angeles
California and talk to Shelly what's up
Shelly
hi hi can you hear me yeah I can how are
you
I am good how are you good good good
good what's up
um sorry I'm a little nervous I'm
nervous too I'm nervous too so we can
just be nervous together
yes um
oh my husband while he was drinking now
that he is sober and is it even possible
uh I don't know what is
um what there's a lot there um why do
you want to move past it
foreign
I can't be connected with him anymore
um I guess I'll just explain I
he was we've been married for uh four
years and he was drinking for I guess
three and a half of those
um but it just progressively got worse
and I did threaten many times to leave
of course but eventually I uh I did
and I went to go stay with my aunt and
uncle and I kind of was just trying to
check out my life because I was just
done and um only after I left did he
finally go to AAA and decide to change
so I came back and the last few months
have just been I I can't get intimate
with him I I can barely hug him honestly
I feel like
when he is even like touching me like I
just get like almost a defense mechanism
you know
how come
what is your body trying to protect you
from
often often when we say I had to step
away from a relationship whether it was
romantic or a friendship or something
like a marriage we step away from
somebody who's struggling with addiction
it's often the behaviors that surround
the addiction so did he hit you did he
cheat on you was he with other people
like what were the things that were
happening while he was not sober
um so he did not hit me or anything like
that
um I mean he got aggressive
with me that like mostly verbally that
he would
pretty much like uh drink excessively
and then if we would go out there were a
lot of times where he would act out and
I mean I lost a lot of friends
um you know because he kind of just
turned into a crazy person
um and you know then sometimes like if I
would go out he would
get drunk and then freak out that I was
out like just and then so why do you
want why do you want to go back you left
yeah you you played a game of chicken
with him for a while which is I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna you never did and
then finally you did
and it sounds like
um we forget this
alcoholism all addictions but alcoholism
um
can often be highly environmental in
nature
and most people when they enter into
sobriety and they go to AAA they don't
realize you got to change friends you
gotta change coping strategies you got
to change places to go hang out you
gotta change everything
and
um
you left the environment
and you found peace
you left the environment and he was able
to Exhale and go get help
so what is it about you wanting to re
like engage in this thing I don't see
anywhere where you love him where you
want to go be with him you want to
rekindle with him
in fact your body's telling you the
exact opposite so why why are you going
to go back
foreign
I mean
I guess
because I I married him and and I I did
go into this with love and I
I wanted I wanted to be that way I guess
and I I want to heal and I guess I
always wanted him to be a certain way
and he wasn't and then
when I left suddenly he's like oh wait
actually I will change and um now that
he is
I guess I just wish that I that I could
feel that way and I wish that we could
just heal can I can I give you an
alternate explanation
yeah
you you had a picture of what marriage
was going to look like you had a picture
of what he was going to look like but
over time you didn't like who you became
yeah and you lost trust in you
and now you're back
and when the sobriety when people get
sober they have to deal with this
ugly reality which is real life
on both sides of the equation that's why
people who struggle with certain
addictions
um their Partners often can't survive
the transition to sobriety because
that's not the person I married or
that's not what I signed up for this
sober person I liked the fun person the
silly person the spontaneous person The
Moody dark person I like that I didn't
like the excesses but I liked that part
and I don't know what to do with this
cheerful guy or this thoughtful guy or
this guy that picks up after himself and
goes to work every day
what about you do you not like in this
new
ly sober husband of yours
I
um it's hard to explain but I think the
main thing is that
I
I
really
um degraded Myself by putting myself
through what I went through
and when I finally went to my aunt and
uncle and my aunt is like
basically my mom
um she really kind of explained to me
that I can't keep doing that and I think
I got that in my head and now
anything that he tries to do just
doesn't help because I'm now like no I
respect myself and I'm not gonna let you
take any advantage ever again like I
don't know is he continuing to try to
take advantage of you while you're sober
no no he's actually trying to be better
and I can see that and I guess that
makes me feel guilty okay so he's not on
the phone so the only person I can talk
to is you and I'm going to give you
probably some wisdom that nobody's given
you okay
okay
um
you chose to go back
yeah
and if you choose to go back and now you
discover that you have power
because a a is about taking a knee it's
about saying I submit I tapped out
what the way I was trying to do life was
not working and it was burning me and
everybody else to the ground
so you've come back and now the tide has
turned and you've got power
and you are killing this guy
you're starving him to death
your dangling love over a great uh
Cavern
and then you're pulling it back every
time he tries
and in a weird way that's that's cruel
do you get what I'm saying
I do and so either here's here's what
most people who re-enter relationships
like this here's the mistake
we just wanted to get back to the way
things used to be
yeah we want it to be I want to be like
remember when we dated and remember when
we laughed all the time and we made out
wherever and remember our wedding and
remember all we wanted to get back to
the way things were
you can't hear me say directly there is
no going back there is only creating
something entirely new
entirely new
you still have the memories you'll still
have to hurt you'll have new boundaries
you'll have some protective measures
but you have to go all in
not in being who you used to be and him
being who he used to be but in being
completely new people for one another so
that you can re-engage this marriage and
if you're not willing to do that don't
torture him
he's got enough on his plate
yeah is that fair
that is that makes a lot of sense are
you willing to
like um am I willing to let go no no no
no no are you willing to
say okay this is what was and it all
fell down
if you've listened to the show for any
length of time you've heard me use the
analogy about 9 11. we could never go
sweep up all the steel and glass and
wood and all the papers that were
scattered for Miles we could never sweep
all that stuff back up and use those
materials to rebuild the Twin Towers in
Manhattan you have to excavate the whole
thing it all has to be moved out thrown
into the dump or recycled and you got to
clear the whole deck out and you got to
design and build something new
see what I'm saying and what you're
trying to do is to sweep up all that
stuff and halfway through sweeping up
the stuff you say I don't want to do
this anymore
yeah
yeah and I'm not debate I I bet man you
could probably make my skin crawl with
some of the things you've experienced
yeah definitely he's screaming in public
the embarrassment the the sexual
advances you didn't want even though you
were married like all the stuff man not
to mention the stuff that you probably
don't know about or you've chosen to not
know about I'm not saying it's easy I'm
just saying you chose to come back
and if you chose to choose to come back
halfway
to a guy who's trying to re-commit his
life to himself and to you that's cruel
yeah
if I'm wrong tell me
it doesn't feel like it's
I almost feel like I'm not choosing like
I'm like and I I want to I want to get
better but I can't help it's like
flashbacks like I see what he's capable
of and it's hard for me to move on from
that that's exactly right and so I'd
recommend a couple things here
um number one you have to develop
your own voice you've got to develop
your strength from the inside out what
does that mean that means you need to
sit with a counselor and
be open and honest about what you
experienced
get those things out of your heads those
flashbacks you say those haunting
memories get them out of your head onto
paper into conversation with somebody
else usually in your situation that's
best had with a therapist you're gonna
have to learn how to create boundaries
very very firm boundaries boundaries
like you cannot swear in this home at me
period if you swear in this home you are
choosing to leave or I am choosing to
leave
you cannot hide money in our home we
will have one single joint checking
account because we're married and we're
going to put like see what I'm saying
like you will have to have really strong
boundaries and then you're gonna have to
practice that when those lightning bolt
thoughts pop in your head the thoughts
of remember that time he started
screaming in a in a restaurant and
caused a scene because he was drunk like
an idiot again you stop and you exhale
not doing that today
he's sober now
he's sober now and I'm gonna practice
going back into restaurants with him
I'm gonna feel the discomfort in my body
I'm gonna lean into that discomfort I'm
not going to run away from it because
otherwise if I keep running that
discomfort becomes reinforced in my own
physiology my body reinforces so next
time it'll send more thoughts and it'll
be louder and more more obtuse and more
graphic I'm going to remember remember
and I'm not saying you forget you'll
always know what he's capable of the new
building you build will have new
reinforcements in it
and you can't base your health or
Wellness on trying to fix him that's his
work he's got to do with himself and his
sponsor and his community
but if you're gonna go back
you've got to do the work to be all in
and be well and honestly I think you
should
I don't know what you've been through so
maybe if we sat down I'd be like Honey
Run Run
just from this limited conversation I
think you're worth that I think he's
worth that
I think this marriage that y'all put put
forth is worth that
if you come back you got to go all then
all in we'll be right back
Dr John deloney here hey it's pumpkin
spice latte season
just kidding it's disgusting but it is
fall it's a little cooler the sun's
going down earlier and God save us
daylight savings time is ending or
starting or whatever the time is
changing again and it can be exhausting
to adjust but make sure you're moving
your body every day getting some
sunlight and getting seven to nine hours
of good sleep each night I can't stress
enough how important this is sleep is
the Cornerstone to physical and mental
health and for me great sleep starts
with a great mattress and that's why I
love dream cloud and right now dream
cloud is running a great offer for our
listeners 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 Dollar Cash
discount that's a total of eight hundred
and forty nine dollars in accessories
and savings you'll get pillows a
mattress protector and luxury sheets so
go to dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloni to get your new mattress to day
all right we are back and hey uh during
the break
um I asked Jenna to go ahead and send
Shelley own your pass change your future
I think that's a great book for her to
pick up and to read through
um so she can begin to
work through what do we do now like the
things have happened that have happened
and there's a period there what do we do
now
um so I'm gonna send that book to her
and hey don't forget to as we're heading
into the holiday season we've got new
questions for humans out we've got um
books out I'm writing a new book and I'm
excited about it and I'll have some more
information on that it won't be ready
for the holidays but
um don't forget to please share the
episodes five star reviews it's helping
so so much and more important than show
ratings way more important than show
ratings I don't even know how to go look
for those way more important than show
ratings is
and new people are finding the show and
new people are opening their eyes and
realizing my marriage doesn't have to be
like this
I can stop generational trauma I can
become the dad that I didn't have
I can pay all my debts off and I can
live free I can solve for freedom
keep passing it along man your reviews
count you're subscribing counts man it
helps so thank you all right let's go to
Samantha The Hope play some Alice in
Chains in Seattle Washington what's up
Samantha
hi Dr D
um nothing much how are you nothing much
Hey listen uh we can have a moment here
but this weekend my Astros defeated your
Seattle team they did but that was a
really good game you know it was um I
was actually at a wedding reception I'm
like we've now had two baseball games it
was a masterpiece that's what my
daughter she's like nine plus nine we
had two baseball games dad and I was I
was more impressed with her math than I
was any of those teams hitting so well
done well done Mariners yelled
represented Seattle well all right so
what's up
um so this is a follow-up call from
about a year ago
your team gave you a heads up
Oh it sounded like
no bring it bring it let's do it either
follow-up calls are usually or one of
two things things have gotten incredible
and I got a new a new question or
things have driven off into the ditch
and often to the ditch okay what
happened what's going on
a year ago I called you about my brother
who
um was using methamphetamine for several
years just kind of how to have healthy
boundaries but still have him in my life
and that was a really helpful call but
now things have changed to where I do
not want him in my life but
I'm having a tough time handling that
what happened
um
um
sorry I don't be sorry
I'm good take a minute take a minute
he was convicted of a crime
where he thankfully was a detective but
it was
um attempting luring of a minor and
um I have two young girls I have a two
and a three-year-old and
I just can't have them in my life and so
um
I
um I mean maybe it was a mistake maybe
it wasn't but I got a hold of all the
online Communications and read through
them because you know my mom and his
girlfriend were like it's not that bad
it's not you know oh this is all a setup
and I'm like I I don't believe you guys
and then
so I've seen it for myself and I know
intuitively in my head this is not a
person I can have around my family but
hold on
somebody along the way possibly your mom
communicated to you
that your body was not to be trusted
I want you to hold on to that sentence
you just you just put forth and put a
period at the end of it before you get
to the butt
intuitively I know this is a person I do
not want around my kids period
okay your body is worth being believed
okay
yes and I have a little girl too and I'm
right there with you
and so I guess I just
I go through like bouts of anger and
rage and then like deep sadness yep and
I mean it's kind of getting cyclical at
this point that my husband's like man
it's
like what's going on in your head and
I'm like my brother I'm sad
um and then I keep reminding myself that
my brother's someone that hurts children
because I'm also a prosecutor and I know
the first time you get caught it's not
the first time so it's
really hard for me to grieve this loss
of this whole family that I had
envisioned
um with his daughters and my fan so it's
just
I don't know how to deal with the anger
and the rage and then the deep sadness
or I don't know maybe if I'm just right
where I'm supposed to be you're right
where you're supposed to be
and I hate to tell you that because
where you are is really painful right
yeah yeah
and you're a prosecutor they didn't talk
about this part in law school the part
where you just sit in it and it hurts
yeah because even behind it all and
behind all the pain the drug use and all
that it's your brother man
and behind all of that
to him huh do I do I
I don't know do I tell him this is it
we're done uh up
you know it's just kind he's still you
know sitting in jail awaiting sentencing
so it's
here's the thing do I write him a letter
uh I would I'd probably write him
several and I probably wouldn't send the
first two or three or four I wrote
but when you're processing a rage and
you're processing grief I want you to
think of it like this you're in your
house
and your smoke alarm's going off so loud
and you just need to get your bearings
right so you can focus on where the fire
is
okay and so when you write that thing
down let it rip man
it's probably not even going to be
coherent and if it is it's going to be
rageful and ultimately not helpful
except that it gets your rage out of
your body onto paper and you can look at
it and you can re-read it and you can
say things like I don't hate you and
wish you hope you die
and right you see you begin to parse it
apart and you begin to demand evidence
from it which parts of these are true
you can never be around my kids you've
burned that bridge to the ground and
that's a choice you made not me that's a
choice you made right so you can begin
to parse that stuff out but right now it
just feels like everything's on fire
and it should be man
your brother hurts kids you know you
know what I mean like it it it should be
have you entered into surrealville
where you've thought about it so much
and gotten so mad and had so many
conversations that it almost becomes
distant like it's not real anymore
yeah so I do keep telling Mike because
time has gone on this happened the last
like you know the initial arresting was
about a year ago and
so because time passed you kind of
forget and so then I have to remind
myself you know especially now that he's
still we're in jail and he sounds
different and he's going to get all
these different treatments but I'm like
I mean honestly maybe this sounds bad
but in my head I'm like I wish you would
have killed someone I could handle you
having killed someone easier than you
hurting a child and so
I'm like it doesn't really matter what
level of therapy you achieve
I can't have you in my life and that's
just really hard I mean that's so final
it is and
um
he made that choice not you
you put up a boundary in response to his
choices but he has to own the choice he
made
and you're just doing the next logical
right thing
that happens to hurt and here's a deeper
hurt
at some point your parents are going to
have to choose him or you and it sounds
like right now they're choosing him
or he's become their cause
or his their guilt and shame over how
whatever happened the addiction to this
to the to the solicitation of minor
they're taking all of that on their
shoulders and so they are so thrilled by
every new moment of sobriety and every
new chip and every new therapeutic
intervention because all of those are a
road back to them feeling less burden
and that's not what this is about
this is about a guy who hurts girls
little kids
and you'll be damned if it's going to be
one of yours
right
yeah
I'm sorry
I'm sorry that thanksgivings will look
different and Christmases will look
different and you'll be guilted for the
next X number of years and here's the
other thing these things have dominoes
and there may come a moment when you
gotta you gotta remove your parents out
of that conversation
or another brother or sister or you have
to block his girlfriend
there are very very few shoulds and have
to's during grief
grief as Kessler says is like a
fingerprint it's Unique to everybody and
so when your husband says hey what's
going on in your head today just say I'm
heartbroken
I'm angry today
and the shoulds are you have to eat and
you gotta sleep and you got to have
human contact and you got to move your
body right you got to do those things
that keep your body functioning so that
you have an opportunity to be well down
the road but right now is at that time
foreign
how long is he going to go away for
it's because he doesn't have a record
um but he doesn't get sentenced till the
21st what do you think it's going to be
more worried about
um probably more around
probably like the two-year Mark okay
I'm not so worried about the in custody
part I'm worried about what you just
talked about the aftermath when everyone
sees but he's getting better and you
know I'm a Christ lover and you know I'm
all about Redemption but I it's not at
the expense of my family and I'm I'm All
About Redemption and I'm also all about
not getting bit twice
and redemption in this case might be
that you meet him for coffee
redemption in this case might be that um
uh
you know
you you show up to your mom's birthday
party by yourself
because they choose who they're going to
invite and when they say we just want to
see the grandkids you say great
as long as there's not a convicted child
um
uh abuser or child solicitor here then
the kids are welcome here that's a
choice you all make
and is here a matter of fact I'm making
it that's the goal here
it's just very simple
yes I'm gonna be around you guys
do what
I have one but my parents are divorced
one parent understands and the other
doesn't
and the longer you try you might just
have to set a boundary yeah yeah the
longer you try to convince that other
person the more exhausted and burned out
you're gonna get
this isn't a conversation
yeah trust your body this isn't a
conversation about more data this isn't
a conversation about more facts or more
oh yeah what about this what
this is somebody's son
and they're choosing to
focus on things
that you're not focusing on and you're
choosing to focus on things that are not
like this isn't a matter of I just need
to convince you or argue argue my
position so well that you change your
mind it's never going to happen
so it's just stating boundaries clear
yeah if you choose to have him come over
then you're just choosing for your
grandkids not to be here you're probably
choosing for me not to be here for a few
years but
you're for sure choosing not to see your
grandkids that's all
simple matter of fact and then you go
home and You Weep bitterly because this
isn't how it's supposed to be
our family members aren't supposed to
hurt kids
our parents are supposed to look at
situations no matter how painful they
are and do the right thing
and be honest and be whole
you can already imagine the future
conversations you're going to have with
your own daughters about your brother
which are scary you already know part of
my brothers is me
if he's capable of right man then you
get on that rabbit hole
this is grief this is grief
the greatest gift you can give to your
husband is to be honest and open and
explain it to him here's what I feel
here's what I'm working on I'm going to
give you permission to talk into my life
if you see me not not doing okay but
also be gentle and curious with me don't
judge me I'm working through it
want things to be different and right
now they're just not
so sorry Sam so so sorry golly
thank you for loving your baby girls
they are great
they are so lucky to have you as their
mom
[Music]
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement and MLS ID
1591 in MLS consumeraccess.org Equal
Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
all right we're back Kelly
say what you just said that was
fantastic
I said to me friends are God's kind of
apology for our families because
sometimes we don't have great families
I have a sibling that is an issue much
like the last caller very similar and so
I understand that that and I think
sometimes God says I'm really sorry
about that here's some really great
friends I'm gonna go with I need a
mulligan on that one so I'm gonna give
you some buddies here's some great
friends make a family out of this
foreign
I just love that idea my friends are an
apology from God
sorry about your family I'm gonna go
with a my bad on that one uh here we go
here's uh let's let's take us let's take
a swift turn left oh man all right let's
go to Andrew in Traverse City one of my
favorite places on the planet what's up
Andrew
hey John how you doing man excellent
excellent man I got some family in
Traverse City what an amazing amazing
place
yeah it's great I'm shivering though
it's a little cold already we actually
got some snow in some places Northern
Michigan today so a little early for
that wow well congratulations it's 111
degrees here in Nashville today so yeah
rub it in uh so what's up man
all right Jen I'm hoping for your
opinion on a health and kind of mental
health related eating and diet question
um I just really need some help figuring
out why I'm struggling craving like
super unhealthy Foods way too often
right now okay um and then kind of how I
put some boundaries in place for myself
around that excellent what's up
all right so I got a three-month-old
baby so I'm a little tired makes sense
uh a boy girl it is a little boy
can we just stop for a minute congrats
man thanks man it's our first really
excited about it's all going okay
perfect perfect perfect okay so uh first
three months in you don't know what day
it is and you it's like Rocky IV and
he's like hit the one in the middle like
you're just exhausted all the time and
uh okay
all right so here's some details I'm I'm
generally a healthy pretty active person
I'd say I eat you know I eat healthy at
home but lately um maybe the past couple
years I've just kind of been tuning into
it a little more I've been struggling
with like just wanting to eat unhealthy
and then eating out like unhealthy like
way too often now way too often is my
opinion but we'll get to that you know
I've noticed a pattern of you know when
I'm stressed or anxious I'm craving like
specifically like fast food oh yeah you
know yeah exactly exactly so the first
thing is again I'm wondering if you can
help me figure out why that is
um but also you know if you can give me
some boundaries you'd recommend around
cheat meals I've heard you talk about
cheat meals and different things but I
feel like I just have an unhealthy view
of food right now sure um and it's super
bothering me man absolutely well thanks
for calling it out and um man this takes
a level of introspection and what I mean
by that this is for all new parents
um or all parents going through
particular life transitions with with
themselves their spouse and their kids
um
noticing hey I've started engaging in
unhealthy Behavior I had this
conversation the other night with myself
about uh social media again I've I've
gotten sucked back into the Vortex and I
was like man I'm just staring at this
thing all day
um and so good for you man for noticing
I am headed down a trail that I don't
want to be I don't want to go down
um all right so I'm gonna give you what
the science says so I can do one up on
my on my opinion and I'm actually going
to throw out a hypothesis that I have
that I've not confirmed scientifically I
don't know that it matters but it makes
sense to me and if any of nutrition
folks actually know the science here I'd
love for you to leave comments uh on
YouTube or shoot me a direct message
um so there is plenty of studies a
number of studies that show when we get
tired
We crave carbohydrates especially sugary
Foods
there's also studies that show when we
are stressed
when the stress cycle has kicked off We
crave sugary carbohydrate-laden Foods
also the Savory the salt and the
fats that drip off a Big Mac
see now you've got me thinking about
fast food and so you craving fast food
right now is your whole life has been
dumped upside down not to mention not
just the baby but let's let's back up
man things have been Wild for the last
year right you found out you're pregnant
yeah I mean the whole the whole world
it's been ramping and ramping and
ramping for sure um and then suddenly it
happens and you're like it's going to be
like this and it's nothing like you
thought it was going to be is it
no not at all you thought they only
pooped twice a day no exactly a thousand
a thousand times a day
um so anyway everything's in
everything's in flux here's so that's
the science so I tell you that to tell
you you're not crazy in fact you are
right in the middle of the bell curve
normal okay you're exhausted you're
stressed you and your wife are having to
navigate a new relationship so you're
married to a new person right now and so
is she
okay I want you to think about it that
that it's that different now
um you have a new variable in your home
you've got new expenses so you've gotten
Financial stress you like you know
you've probably already done the
calculation so if Putin actually invades
Ukraine full-on or launches a nuke it
would be this many years until right
until the draft I mean you've probably
already done those calculations like
every parent has
it's a mess it's a mess my here's my
hypothesis okay
um I think one of two things
when they're fight or flight system
kicks off it actually pulls blood away
from the digestive system and and sends
it to them our muscles
okay we don't need to be eating and
digesting food we are fighting or
fleeing for our lives okay that's just
how our stress response system works
the cheapest quickest forms of calories
or energy so remember our bodies in
fight or flight assume we are fighting
something or running from something
it craves the simplest calories you can
get which is a cheap simple carbohydrate
the problem is
we're not running or fighting anything
we're just sitting in traffic or dealing
with emails or changing another diaper
right and our stress system is saying we
need more energy we don't really we
don't really because we're just sitting
there
and man there are sugary cheap calories
everywhere and now they'll just deliver
my to your house you don't even have to
move you don't even have to have real
money you can just push a button on your
phone and ah it just shows up you see
what I'm saying like so we now live in a
world that your body was not designed to
live in
so I think that our again this is total
speculation this is just the story I've
told myself I think the fight-or-flight
systems activation
would if I'm running for my life I'm in
the middle of a long protracted fight
grabbing something like a piece of fruit
grab me some sugar in my body 5000 years
ago would give me a sudden burst of
quick energy that would not take a lot
of digestive energy and would allow me
to get back in the fight
amen a Twinkie is like a super version
of that right or an Arby's sandwich or
french fries french fries
um for sure the other idea I have is
this happened last night I'm writing a
new book it was midnight I had I had
chapters due last night
um
I'm out of energy I'm out of gas and I
found myself down there I grabbed a
protein bar but it's one of those
protein bars that are really like
Snickers bars they just shove protein in
it and they trick you into I mean they
lie to you and you go along with the LIE
there's some sort of health food when
it's really not it was one of those kind
of bars I feel like the sugar was a
quick energy boost for a body that was
so taxed on sleep I'm just exhausted
right now
um and so since I don't have my normal
rest my body is going to go for some
cheap explosive energy really fast to
try to prop me up until I can get to
sleep again that's my hypothesis there I
don't know if that's accurate I don't
know that it matters what what does
matter is the science says when you're
exhausted the science says when you're
stressed we reach for trash and we eat
we overeat to we eat more trash than
normal okay oh for sure so what do you
what have you tried to do to to head
this off at the pass
well I mean it's gotten worse since you
know my little guy was born three months
ago and I think you're right on with
that hypothesis
um but you know the things I've tried
have been just like you know saying like
you know no ahead of time and like you
know taking different routes home and
like bringing extra food to work and it
feels like the issue I'm dealing with
you know again I mentioned I've noticed
it start over the last couple years of
course it gets it's gotten exacerbated
by you know my baby is like I'll come
out of like a really tough work meeting
or a really tough case or something like
that and it's like man if I just like go
park somewhere and eat some fast food
I'll like be able to take a breather and
like that dopamine or I'm not sure what
exactly it is will hit and I'll just
feel better and I'll drive away and then
that was a kid I'm like how this pattern
is not good for me so you know I'm not
really answering the question but I
haven't tried many specific things I was
kind of hoping you could help me with
that yeah okay so you nailed it
it's the if I just statement
okay so the nerd were in the nerd World
here's what we're looking for we're
looking for The Gap
the gap between stressful meeting
and the thought that follows which is I
just need to get some satiating food and
then I'll feel better
you need the gap between stimulus and
response stressful meeting Big Mac
frustrating interaction with my wife bag
of Gummy candies screaming kid I'm just
gonna go grab a pizza we don't need to
we don't need to eat here tonight
because you know on the back end
dopamine is about motivation it's
actually not about pleasure even I've
been wrong on this Andy huberman has
done a great job uh explaining this but
there's no such thing like dopamine hits
that's not really how that works
dopamine is a molecule of motivation and
the moment the ball gets rolled down the
hill
um think of it this way like a
teeter-totter the moment it's that it
sits down and begins to the other end it
starts to go up on the teeter-totter you
know dopamine gets the lever gets pushed
towards pleasure
as soon as you bite into that Arby
sandwich or into that piece of pizza
your body has to has to flatten out that
uh teeter-totter and it has one way of
doing it pain
that's why you feel ashamed that's why
you feel bad that's why you feel
because it's got to hit the other end of
the of it it's got to hit the other end
of the teeter-totter so here's what
we're going to do we're going to opt out
of the system completely because you
know it's not true
if I can just go get something to eat it
will make this last meeting feel better
that's a false statement
it's a lie it's not true
and so you've heard me on this show say
demand evidence
ask yourself what is my body trying to
protect me from
identify the behavior for me it's it's
trash eating too it used to be calling
old friends it used to be checking it
whatever your behavior is that you want
to stop right before you do it
ask yourself what is my body trying to
protect me from
some people text old girlfriends some
people grab another drink and then
another drink some people just pick out
their phone and start scrolling some
people roll up to a pornography website
whatever
ask yourself as you're entering into
this Behavior you don't want to do what
is my body trying to protect me from I
had a crappy meeting
makes me feel like I'm gonna get fired
and then here's the magic words we're
going to demand evidence am I gonna get
fired no
or am I gonna get fired yeah if I don't
make another sale I'm gonna get fired I
should probably look for another job
right or I should probably start getting
on the phone right so we can solve that
problem with actual things actual
actions are gonna work
but an Arby's sandwich has never solved
anything it just hasn't
right is that fair
yeah it is fair it makes sense and I
think you're on it more tactically
I've had Seasons where I took my debit
card out of my wallet and gave it to my
wife
well yeah delete all apps off your phone
when you're trying to change an
addictive habit you have to create
systems that allow you to be successful
all the junk has to be out of the house
I don't have like I don't have access to
money I just can't go I can't stop there
and you're gonna run out of gas at one
point it's gonna be so super annoying
and we're playing a long game with your
health it's worth the it's worth the
exchange
but in this early stage that's why if
you're an alcoholic and you're
struggling with alcohol you got to dump
everything down the sink you got to get
out of your house start day one
you have to get stop hanging out with
people who go to bars day too right you
got to make some radical life movements
uh life changes you do too you're gonna
have to practice new coping behaviors
it may be after a hard meeting I'm gonna
go for a walk
maybe after a hard meeting I'm going to
call a friend maybe after a hard beating
I'm gonna pull out a journal that I got
for like eight bucks you know at
Walgreens and I'm gonna write down
here's what I felt in that last meeting
we're going to practice new copings on
the way home I'm just going to swing by
the gym for 15 minutes and do a 15
minute workout that's it
see what I'm saying we're building in
things along the way that are going to
become new habits for us to start yeah
but you got to go scorched Earth on the
prevention side
okay I am not I'm somebody and I've
learned this the hard way
I can't do moderation or let me put it
this way I'm choosing for that not to be
a battle that I fight I've got too many
other battles internally that I'm trying
to trying to deal with so I have to say
no
I've got to I can't have
some fast food sometime I just I I just
I don't I just have to walk away from it
if I do have it I'm going all in man I'm
gonna get super sized I'm gonna get five
fries I'm gonna get two virgins I mean
I'm going all in
um and I've made peace with that too
that's okay I just do it so rarely now
okay this weekend me and my son went and
got a hotel we went on like a little
father-son hunting trip dude I ate
myself into a coma it was awesome and
because I'm playing a long game here we
had fun we're making memories being
silly and I was back on the wagon this
morning okay
um you're not there yet
here's what I'm worried about that food
is becoming medication for you is that
right
I I think that's 100 accurate yeah
that's what I called did you learn that
at home is this new where'd you pick
that up from
I I don't know um my mom had cancer when
I was four and she had like all these
different doctors having her on these
like fad diets so that she wouldn't they
wouldn't come back and I knew you're
gonna ask me that question and I was
like do I even bring that up or not I
don't know if that's accurate or not
absolutely man listen listen how that's
encoded in your body
but somehow food is the solution to fill
in the blank
is your mom still with you
yeah she she made it yeah man food
solves everything
and intellectually you know that's
insane
and it's not that insane healthy eating
is really good for you right and it's
preventative in a number of different
areas
um
but that's particularly encoded in your
body
food will solve this
it's just become very perverted and now
it's food makes me feel better
and then food makes me uh or I I I
overeat and then I feel ashamed and then
I want to hide and then the whole thing
starts over again
and so I'm not telling you to get a
phobia about food I'm not telling you to
head down a disorder eating track or
anything like that I'm just suggesting
that you create systems of the person
you want to become I want to become a
guy who's a good Steward of his body I'm
going to create an identity that way and
then I'm going to create habits that
make that happen
foreign garbage
even this morning
um my new friend Jade warshaw here she
was had made these incredible vegan
whatever Kumbaya muffins that I think
they did yoga over them I don't know
they were awesome and they were dusted
with essential oils or something she
walked by and she said oh you don't eat
sweets
like that's an identity I have around
the office and I said okay oh but today
I will because they just look delicious
and so
um
but are you making a conscious choice to
step off the wagon at that point and
you're able at this point you're you're
where you can step right back on yes and
it's been years it's been years okay
and I also know often when I step back
on when I step off the wagon
intentionally uh that's that's one of my
that's my one of my internal mantras I'm
a guy who doesn't fall off the wagon but
I will step off the wagon and roll
around in the mud every once in a while
and then I'll climb back up and I
usually slip off the wagon four or five
times trying to get back on and then I
get back on the wagon but that's an
identity I have I'm a guy that didn't
fall off the wagon and that means uh I
have to be really conscious of when I'm
exhausted
really conscious of when I'm stressed
out
so I'm it like I mentioned a couple
times I'm writing a new book right now I
started a a
new exercise program and a new eating
regimen
about a month out of this process
so that when I hit this thing I'd be
ready to rock and roll I wouldn't have
to also be fighting my exercise routine
and my diet routine does that make sense
yes that's just me trying to be
intentional because I've lost I've
failed it every time and all my other
writing projects dude I end up just a
goofy Mess by the time it's all over and
I I'm just tired of reclaiming my life
every time so this time my identity is
I'm a guy that takes care of himself and
who's going to take care of himself
through this entire stressful process
that's just where you are and so if you
think about it I want to create an
identity
I want to be this kind of Dad I'm a dad
who's a good Steward of his one body I'm
gonna teach my kids what that looks like
and while I learned that I can't have
any cash in my wallet because I'll go
I'll go to fast food
that makes sense it makes a hundred
percent sense yeah thank you and by the
way
you don't suck and you're not a loser
and you're not a failure you're a
first-time dad
you've never done this before this is
new
and you're pretty young and so this is
probably your first or second big job
and this is your first time dealing with
what I you know adult stress this is
your first time being married to
somebody who just had a kid
this is your first time not sleeping for
months on end all these things are new
so cut yourself some slack you are way
ahead of the game man you woke up three
months in and you're like whoa that's a
lot of Burger King
I should probably put the burrito down
and back the thing up
good for you man that's awesome
let's focus on identities first not
goals let's focus on who we're going to
become and this is a great exercise for
you and your wife too
um let's focus on who we're gonna become
and then let's reverse engineer that
with a series of behaviors
and food's not the enemy fast food's not
the enemy
um sugar isn't I'm not going to war over
sugar ready I'm just not I got too much
other stuff to do
I'm going to be about the things that I
can positively impact because that's the
kind of guy I want to be
it's kind of guy you want to be
and you'll get there man thank you so
much for your call holler back as you
make this uh as you make this turn and
I'll be willing to walk with you every
step of the way thank you brother Andrew
congratulations on your little boy we'll
be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we're back hey thanks for
joining us today on the Walking
alongside me and our callers today as
they are trying to figure out what to do
next the song of the day is by the great
one and only Michelle Branch
for those of you ogs who love yourself a
little
existential singer-songwriter from back
in the day songs called everywhere and
it goes like this turn it inside out so
I can see the part of you that's
drifting over me and when I wake you're
you're never there but when I sleep
you're everywhere
just tell me how I got this far just
tell me why you're here and who you are
because every time I look you're never
there and every time I sleep you're
always there because you're everywhere
to me and when I close my eyes it's you
I see you're everything I know that
makes me believe I'm not alone
I mean except in reality you are alone
which is what makes you dreaming so
awesome we'll see you soon